N'avez vous jamais rêvé
de construire votre propre royaume?
De créer votre propre monde pour faire
les choses comme vous en aviez envie?
C'est ce qu'a fait un Italien nommé
Giorgio Rosa en créant sa propre île
dans la mer Adriatique, l'île de la Rose.
Pourquoi a-t-il fait ça?
Comment? Était-il seul?
Etait-il fou?
Qu'en est-il de cette île aujourd'hui?
Pour vous raconter cette histoire
incroyable,
je serai accompagné de Poisson Fécond
qui parraine ce premier épisode.
Bienvenue dans le Cabinet Curiouz.
Qui est ce Giorgio Rosa, qui a réussi à créer une île
et son propre État indépendant.
Giorgio Rosa est né en 1925 à Bologne.
Il devient ingénieur en mécanique
avec un petit grain de folie,
mais également beaucoup d'intelligence.
Un homme qui a soif de liberté et qui rêve
de créer son propre espace
avec ses propres règles.
Son idée insolite de créer son propre État
indépendant germe en 1956,
lorsqu'il considère que les Etats-Unis
ont réduit l'Italie à l'état d'esclavage.
Il explique dans ses mémoires son souhait,
son désir, de créer un endroit
où la liberté existe vraiment.
L'idée m'est venue de faire une île
où la vraie liberté était,
où les gens intelligents pouvaient
avancer et où les ineptes étaient chassés.
Et là, j'ai étudié la situation
et j'ai trouvé la possibilité
de construire une île.
Mais techniquement,
comment a-t-il pu créer une île au milieu
de rien? Et avec quels moyens techniques?
C'est la grande question!
Pendant plusieurs années,
Giorgio vagabonde dans la région
à la recherche du lieu idéal
pour concevoir son pays utopique.
Il choisit une zone de construction
à 12 kilomètres au large de Rimini,
à peu
près à 20 minutes des côtes en bateau.
L'endroit n'est pas choisi au hasard,
car il est à 500 mètres des eaux
territoriales italiennes.
Giorgio est dans son bon droit puisque cette zone,
comme toutes les eaux
internationales,
n'appartient à personne.
Même s'il rencontre quelques
problèmes techniques et financiers,
Giorgio ne se laisse pas abattre
et commence la conception d'une île en 1964.
Une construction pas simple qui prend beaucoup
de temps en raison
des conditions météorologiques peu idéales.
Pour concevoir
la structure de son île,
Giorgio va faire preuve
d'une ingéniosité hors du commun.
Conscient qu'il n'est pas en mesure de faire une île
avec du sable,
il se met dans l'idée de créer
une plateforme sur l'eau,
soutenue par des colonnes en acier.
Sauf que, transporter des tubes d'acier
en pleine mer, c'est très cher
et c'est très compliqué.
Mais Giorgio a une idée révolutionnaire.
Il comprend que les colonnes,
lorsqu'elles sont creuses,
peuvent flotter sur l'eau et du coup,
il n'y a plus qu'à les laisser
flotter pour les tracter.
Et ça, ça coûte rien.
Il peut, par ce moyen,
transporter les colonnes de sa structure
jusqu'à la zone de construction.
Une fois arrivé,
Giorgio libère les colonnes et fait
en sorte qu'elles se remplissent d'eau pour couler,
reprendre du poids et se
poser sur le fond de la mer
pour poser les fondations qui soutiendront
son Etat de liberté.
On n'est pas tout à fait sur une île paradisiaque
avec du sable
et des cocotiers.
N'est ce pas, Fabien?
Evidemment, la plateforme ne passe pas inaperçue,
notamment auprès des autorités
de la Capitainerie de Rimini,
qui demandent immédiatement l'arrêt
pur et simple des travaux.
Pour comprendre pourquoi,
il faut savoir que certaines zones
avaient été attribuées précédemment à ENI,
la société nationale italienne des hydrocarbures.
Giorgio reçoit donc ses premières menaces.
Mais les menaces ne l'arrêtent pas.
Il continue sa construction jusqu'à
ouvrir son île au public à l'été 1967.
Même s'il reste encore beaucoup de choses
à créer, il est possible de la visiter.
Il continue les améliorations
au fur et à mesure du temps
et cette plateforme,
de 400 mètres carrés,
trônant à 26 mètres au dessus du fond de la mer,
est prête à accueillir des bâtiments
et même un deuxième étage
pour doubler l'espace disponible.
Giorgio commence petit à petit
à installer des éléments sur son île,
comme un restaurant, une boutique de
souvenirs ou encore un bureau de poste.
Rappelez-vous que,
comme sa plateforme est dans les eaux internationales,
elle se trouve en dehors
des lois de l'Italie et n'a besoin
d'aucune autorisation
pour ses aménagements.
C'est à ce moment précis
que les ennuis vont commencer.
La plateforme commence à attirer
l'attention de la population italienne
jusqu'à amener des personnes
de toute l'Europe.
L'Île fait la une des journaux et devient
un véritable lieu de tourisme,
un lieu propice à faire la fête, principalement.
Le souhait de Giorgio,
est que son île puisse être reconnue par
l'ONU pour devenir une île indépendante.
Mais, rien ne va se passer comme prévu.
Lassé d'attendre,
Giorgio s'autoproclame donc indépendant
le 1er mai 1968.
L'Île devient une micro-nation où il
crée son propre gouvernement.
L'Île dispose d'une présidence, de ses
départements
avec son ministre des Finances, de l'Intérieur
et des Affaires étrangères.
Oui, tout à fait.
D'ailleurs, l'île se développe à vitesse grand V.
Au point d'avoir sa propre
monnaie, son propre timbre,
son propre drapeau et même sa propre
langue : l'espéranto
Saluton !
Je l'ai appris l'espéranto d'ailleurs.
Par ces dispositifs,
Giorgio Rosa souhaite montrer une réelle
indépendance vis à vis de la République italienne
et ainsi,
asseoir sa souveraineté.
La même année, le gouvernement italien
commence à s'en mêler et à s'agacer.
Nous sommes alors en 1968 et l'État
italien n'apprécie pas
la conférence de presse qui présente
officiellement le projet aux médias,
très attirés par l'étrangeté de ce scoop.
En fait, quand le gouvernement italien
apprend l'existence de cette île,
il fait immédiatement un blocus naval,
faisant en sorte que personne
ne puisse y accoster.
C'est du sérieux, là.
Mais alors, pourquoi le gouvernement s'en mêle
puisque l'île se situe dans les
eaux internationales?
Eh bien, pour une raison surprenante :
même si cette île se situe en dehors
des eaux internationales,
elle demeure une source d'inquiétude
pour le gouvernement italien
et la police italienne.
Le trafic maritime vers l'île de la Rose
est très important et crée
forcément des revenus touristiques.
Du coup, le gouvernement va prétexter
qu'il s'agit d'un stratagème
pour échapper aux impôts italiens.
Ce n'était pas la seule explication.
En fait, d'après la République italienne,
cette île pourrait aussi constituer
un risque pour la sécurité de l'OTAN.
Elle pourrait, par exemple, offrir une sorte de couverture
aux sous-marins nucléaires soviétiques.
En réalité, cette piste est un peu bancale,
car Giorgio Rosa était
de droite et se déclarait libéral.
Donc, c'est pas tout à fait
comme les Soviétiques.
C'est un peu l'opposé.
Mais l'Etat
était bien déterminé à balayer l'île.
Le gouvernement veut alors détruire
l'île coûte que coûte.
l'Armée rentre en jeu et 55 jours seulement
après la déclaration de l'indépendance
de l'île de la Rose.
Les soldats assiègent la plateforme qui,
à l'époque, n'avait qu'un seul habitant :
un naufragé qui s'y était
installé après une tempête.
Giorgio s'oppose activement contre
cette prise de pouvoir
et envoie un télégramme au Président
de la République italienne de l'époque :
Giuseppe Saragat, sans recevoir de réponse.
Dans les semaines qui suivent,
Giorgio recevra néanmoins de nombreuses
propositions de rachat,
qu'il refuse toutes inlassablement.
Par la suite, le ministère de la Marine Marchande
entame une procédure judiciaire
afin que la plateforme soit détruite.
Rosa a déposé un recours qui est
rejeté
et, en novembre 1968,
des équipes commencent à amener à Rimini
tout ce qui se trouvait sur l'île
en prévision de la démolition
à l'explosif.
Début 1969,  la démolition commence
sous le regard impuissant de Rosa,
qui aura tout
fait pour que cela n'arrive jamais.
Malgré tout, la structure résiste et c'est
finalement, courant février,
une tempête qui finira par la faire
disparaître définitivement.
Un bouleversement pour Giorgio Rosa,
qui dit avoir ressenti la même douleur
que si on avait tué un membre de sa
famille ou l'un de ses proches.
Exactement Fabien.
Et au final, la République de la Rose n'a jamais
été reconnue comme étant
un Etat à part entière.
D'ailleurs, cette affaire
est unique en son genre.
Il n'y a pas eu de précédent
dans l'histoire juridique.
Et donc, pour éviter que ce genre de scénario
arrive à nouveau,
l'ONU a repoussé les frontières
des eaux internationales de 11 à 22 km,
partout dans le monde.
Donc, Giorgio a, d'une certaine façon,
démontré une faille dans le système
et... le système entier a dû s'adapter
face à la force de la vision d'un seul.
Et c'est en 2017 que Giorgio Rosa
est décédé à l'âge de 92 ans.
Lorenzo Rosa, son fils,
décrit son père comme une personne très
précise, détaillée et très organisée.
Un ingénieur dans un sens
presque allemand du terme.
Sauf que pour cette petite veine de folie,
qui l'a conduit à vouloir se construire
une plateforme, puis à en faire un état
hors des eaux territoriales, ce qui,
en quelque sorte, faisait de lui
le prince des anarchistes.
Rosa a accepté, peu avant
sa mort, que son histoire soit adaptée en film.
L'incroyable histoire
de l'île de la Rose.
Si vous souhaitez en découvrir plus
sur une Giorgio Rosa et son île utopique,
je pense que vous adorez le visionner.
Bon, après, il y a de grandes libertés
entre le scénario et la véritable
histoire, mais le film reste passionnant.
Et je peux vous l'affirmer, puisque je
l'ai vu moi-même, et c'était vraiment kiffant.
N'hésitez pas à me partager des idées
de sujets insolites
dont vous avez envie que je parle dans un prochain
Cabinet Curiouz.
D'ailleurs, dites-moi ce que vous en pensez de ce
nouveau format et de ce nouveau décor.
Merci à Poisson Fécond d'avoir
participé au premier épisode.
Je vous invite à découvrir sa chaîne
passionnante et frétillante d'idées.
D'ailleurs, nous avons sorti ensemble
une vidéo aujourd'hui sur sa chaîne,
sur d'autres utopies insolites,
un petit peu comme l'Île de la Rose.
Si vous ne me connaissez pas,
je m'appelle toujours Fabien Olicard,
Pas Sébastien, pas Olivier,
mais bien Fabien Olicard.
Merci à vous qui likez cette vidéo,
et vous pouvez vous abonner à cette
chaîne si vous le souhaitez.
C'est gratuit.
En activant la cloche, ça aide toujours.
Vous trouverez ici une autre vidéo sur
d'étranges histoires, sur l'intuition.
Et ici, une vidéo
sur les paradoxes visuels.
Prenez soin de vous!
A très bientôt. Tchao!